Elon Musk was over in Poland yesterday
with a friend of mine there's a fellow I
know by the name of Ben Shapiro they
were over there touring aitz and then
afterward they had a conversation and
Elon made the claim that
Dei is anti-Semitic the diversity
actually inclusion I mean you should
always be always be wary of any name
that sounds like it could come out of a
George Orwell book okay that's never a
good sign um and uh because it sounds
like sure diversity Equity inclusion
these all sound like nice words but but
that what what it really means is
discrimination on the basis of race uh
sex and um sexual orientation and uh and
and it's against Merit um and and thus I
think is fundamentally
anti-semitic fundamentally
anti-semitic some people saw that as a
non seiter I do not I think think Elon
is totally right here but the
implications of this go far far beyond
anti-Semitism or the Jewish people Elon
says diversity equity and inclusion Dei
is
anti-Semitic totally agree totally agree
with that it is because the Jews have
done very well the Jews perform very
well they succeed at very high levels
you could be the most jew-hating
anti-semite in the world you have to
admit they've they've been pretty
successful over the Millennia haven't
they if you're a Christian surely you
would say the Jews are obviously a
gifted people what other people could
bring forth the Virgin Mary what other
people would bring forth our Lord and
savior Lord and Savior the the Lord of
Lord and King of Kings Master of the
Universe h no other people and and even
if you're less religiously inclined you
look and you see the Jews do very well
in all these IND histories they score
very well on IQ tests right so Dei which
says that we need to uh factor in other
things we need to prioritize other
things than Merit and work and success
and IQ and blah blah blah that's going
to be effectively anti-semitic you you
saw this in University admissions in the
US a 100 years ago there were Jewish
quotas because the Jews were getting
into the schools too much but you
wouldn't say that Dei is just anti
antisemitic you would say it's also
anti-asian because Asians share a lot of
those attributes as
well C certainly in affirmative action
you would say that that's anti- agan we
just had a a major court case about this
that the schools say oh yeah you've done
very well on your sat you've scored very
well you're the valorian yeah but you're
Asian so sorry we're going to give your
your spot in the university to someone
of a more privileged race than you are
ironically we're going to say they're
they're a less privileged race so we're
going to give them a special priv
privilege and they're going to take your
spot sorry so you'd say it's it's
anti-asian you you could make all of
those claims the one thing you can't say
is that it's
anti-white that's the weird
part because white people also do pretty
well you know historically they've done
pretty well on the statistics and they
score well on the tests and everything
but you're not allowed to say that Dei
is anti-white that's that's not one of
the reasons for which you can criticize
it anti-semitic that's okay anti-asian
that's okay
anti-white not so much it's even deeper
than that it it's not only that you
can't do anything about these policies
that
explicitly discriminate against white
people because they are white in hiring
in University admissions in promotions
in
everything you can't even talk about it
you can't even mention it unless you are
willing to suffer social consequences
for for it unless you work for a company
that lets you speak your opinion I work
for a conservative company my job is to
State my opinion and I have accepted the
fact that I will incur social
ostracization and all sorts of calumny
in the press for stating simple truths I
have accepted that and so in my job I'm
allowed to at least point out that these
policies explicitly and intentionally
discriminate against white people but if
you're a middle manager at some company
you can't really say that
you could lose your job if you're at a
university and you're just trying to get
a good grade and graduate you can't
really say that too openly or you will
be discriminated against if you work for
the government oh my
goodness if you work for a university
and you ever said that you would lose
your job in two seconds that that is a
major political problem I agree I just
think Elon is scratching the surface
here when he says yeah Dei is
anti-Semitic it totally is and that is
one of the reasons to oppose it and and
these sorts of policies are anti-asian
yeah that's true that's that's another
reason to oppose it and it's
anti-white I consider that a pretty big
reason to oppose it
and we have a political climate right
now where you're not even allowed to
mention that it is so not only legally
acceptable to discriminate against white
people but socially encouraged to malign
white people all the time that if you
ever speak up and say hey maybe we
shouldn't you know like legally
discriminate against them you will
you'll be called a Nazi for that that
that is a actually a deeper political
problem than the Direct effects of any
of these Dei
policies say yes and Elon yes and but
it's it's so much worse than all that
Senator Tim Scott has just announced
some happy news he is getting
married Senator Scott is you know a
little a little bit older he's 58 years
old then he thought he would remain a
bachelor he's obviously a very busy guy
he's a politician politicians don't
always have time for a family but he
just proposed to his girlfriend Mindy He
Said She Said Yes Mindy thank you for
making me the luckiest man in the world
he who finds a wife finds what is good
and receives favor from the Lord that's
from Proverbs
18:22 as uh Senator Scott tweeted out is
great for him he's 58 she's 47 though a
lady never tells so obviously this is a
later- in life marriage but a wonderful
I it's terrific and I wish the many many
years of happiness and I've had the
pleasure of meeting Senator Scott on a
couple occasions and he's a really
terrific guy so I think that's all
great but there is a little voice inside
me a little voice of that political
cynic crying out inside me that makes me
wonder hold on a second
here is Senator Scott in the running to
be Trump's VP is
because not everyone is called to
marriage Senator Scott made it 58 years
without getting married and if you make
it to 58 without getting married you
probably could go the rest of your life
without getting married he's getting
married now just after he drops out of
the presidential race before the nominee
who he's endorsed picks a running mate
even today in our very Loosey Goosey
culture I think he probably have to be
married to be a vice presidential
Contender haven't had all that many
bachelors in American history serve as
president is this sending signals about
who Trump is going to pick we know that
Senator Scott is in contention for it I
don't know and maybe I'm not saying it's
totally cynical and they're just getting
married as a political Arrangement or
something they might love each other
very much and I think it's good to get
married so it's all wonderful but if
there already was chatter on the vep
stakes about Senator Scott I think the
chatter has increased in volume that was
a good clip huh that was a good clip and
you know it and I know it and we both
know it well if you want more you got to
ring the bell and then you'll get the
notifications and you'll see more of
this face and hear my malif fluous tones
and we'll get to spend some time
together all right see you next time